لقد حصلت على ذلك على etsy
أراد لصنا في
العالم ، الأسقف ،
مرحباً أيها الأولاد ، من الجيد جدًا أن ألتقي
بكم شخصيًا
[موسيقى] لقد
وضعتني في
إطار هذه السكتات الدماغية
وداعًا جون هارتلي
بصفتي
أجنبيًا ،
مرحبًا دواين ،
كيف حالك؟
حسنًا ، أنت
جيد جدًا ، شكرًا لك ، من الجيد التحدث
إليك
، من الجيد التحدث إليك أيضًا ،
ومبروك على الفيلم الذي
شاهدته ، إنه جيد جدًا ،
نعم ،
أعتقد أننا صنعنا فيلمًا جيدًا ، شكرًا لك ،
نعم إنه حقًا  فيلم أكشن ولكني
كنت أستمتع كثيرًا بمشاهدته
وشعرت أنكم كنتم
تستمتعون بالتصوير ، لقد كان الأمر كذلك ،
لقد استمتعنا كثيرًا بهذا الفيلم ،
أنت تعلم أننا لم نتمكن من الحفاظ على
وجهك  أعرف أنه حدث الفيلم فقط ، قمنا
بتصوير القليل منه مغطى مسبقًا
ثم عدنا
أه أثناء الطمع واضطررنا إلى الانتهاء من
تصوير الفيلم ، لذلك كنا نفعل
كل ما في وسعنا
لتفتيح المجموعة وجعلها ممتعة
وأه وأكثر  أنت تعلم أن روستن ثوربر
كتب سيناريو رائعًا أخرجه آغ  reat
الفيلم وقضيت وقتًا رائعًا مع gaul
، إنه أمر رائع للغاية العمل مع gal
لأنها محترفة جدًا
لدرجة أنها منضبطة جدًا لتضعها
ثم تنفصل عن الضحك
هكذا تمامًا ومن
دواعي سرورها أن تجعلها تضحك
بنفس الشيء مع  روس ، لذا فأنتم معجبون بكم جميعًا
ولكن ليس ريان رينولدز ،
أنا أحب غال رايان ،
سيتعين علينا أن نصفير ذلك
ولكن في الواقع كان لديك كيمياء رائعة
معهم أحب أنا أحب ريان ، لقد عرفت
ريان
آه أحب أن أقول إننا مثل
زوجان عجوزان آه
تعلمون أننا كنا متزوجين
إلى الأبد لقد عرفت رايان طوال مسيرتي المهنية
وقمنا بعمل هوبز وشو معًا كان لديه
دور صغير في ذلك ثم بالطبع
عدنا وقمنا باللون الأحمر  لاحظ ذلك ، فأنا
أتطلع إلى فعل المزيد مع ريان ،
فهو مشهور بنكاته ومزاحه في الواقع
، هل فعل أيًا من هذه النكات
يا رفاق ،
دائمًا ما يكون
ريان فريدًا جدًا وريان
مختلفًا تمامًا ، أعتقد
أنه أيضًا منضبط جدًا عندما  يأتي
ليضع وهو ذكي شرير
لكنه  كما أنه ذكي
ومضحك للغاية لأنه في كثير من الأحيان
سيقول أشياء في أعلى
ما يحدث هنا ، سيقوله فقط
في هذه المشاهد وسيكون الأمر مضحكًا للغاية
وأنت تعلم أننا كنا جميعًا دائمًا  الضحك
الخراب يتطلب
إهدار المال
والوقت
كان لديك دلو كبير على الرغم من
أننا فعلنا ذلك ،
نعم ، هل
هو 200 مليون
جيدًا ، نعم أعني
أنني فشلت في الرياضيات
آه
مرتين ، لذا فقد كنت في مكان ما حول
ذلك ربما
بضعة دولارات على
ما يرام وقد ذكرت أطمع وأنا  أعلم
أنه كان صعبًا جدًا على الجميع
خلال ذلك الوقت ،
كيف كان الأمر بالنسبة لكم يا رفاق أثناء إطلاق النار أثناء
الوباء
، كان الأمر صعبًا للغاية بالنسبة لنا
تمامًا كما أعتقد أنه كان يمثل تحديًا
للجميع في جميع أنحاء العالم سواء
كنت في المنزل
ولم تكن قادرًا على ذلك  اذهب إلى العمل أو
كنت قادرًا على الحصول على نوع من وظيفة العمل
أه للذهاب إليها كان الأمر
صعبًا حقًا وأعتقد أيضًا أن ما
جعله يمثل تحديًا ،
كنا من أوائل الأفلام التي ظهرت في
هوليوود ،
لذلك
لم يكن هناك مخطط لنا حقًا
ث  لقد عاد e لقد عاد فيلم توم كروز ،
وقد عاد باتمان ، وكان هناك عدد
قليل من الأفلام التي عادت
وتم إغلاق الأفلام يسارًا
ويمينًا لأنهم
كانوا مغطاة وتم تغطية النجوم لذا
تأكدنا من ذلك  عندما بدأنا ،
كان لدينا أكثر
السياسات صرامة وكنا في طريقنا لذلك
مهما كانت الاستوديوهات الأخرى تفعل فيما
يتعلق بسياساتها المرغوبة أه قلنا
أنه من
الرائع
الآن أن تكون أكثر صرامة الآن
وسوف نتخلى عن الأمر  إلى طاقمنا لمعرفة ما إذا كنت
تريد العودة إلى العمل في ظل هذه
الظروف وكانت هذه الظروف
صارمة للغاية ، فقد تم عزل الجميع
ولكننا لم يتم إغلاقنا مطلقًا وكان لدينا
ما تعرفه
عن طرق الخشب في ذلك الوقت كان لدينا
حقًا  الأكثر
أمانًا خلال ذلك الوقت الذي أنا فخور جدًا به ،
والأهم من ذلك ، سأخبرك أن هذا
فخور جدًا بالطاقم الذي قاموا
بعمل رائع ، حسنًا ، شكرًا جزيلاً لك
على وقتك.
أتحدث إليكم أكثر ولكن هذا هو
وقتنا ، لذا أشكركم جزيل الشكر ،
وأقدر ذلك